we are 10 days from the draft and we are
thrilled to have here on the rich eisen
show
fresh office is umpteen point oh mock
draft mike uh
my friend from espn who will if i'm not
mistaken will be part of the abc
triple cast coverage from cleveland uh
starting 10 days from today
our friend todd mcshape back here on the
rich housing show how are you todd
i'm good man i'm i'm confused i have no
idea what you're talking about
well look that's okay it's hunter long
from bc or pat fryer from penn state the
number two tight end i mean that's
that's all i can focus on right now you
know what todd that's good that's what
you need this is
this is it this is your tax season man
this is it like this is
we got this coming up i need you focused
on micah parsons and everybody else and
i don't need you
you can't be you can't be talking about
leeds football club like you can't be
doing that all right so
it's all good um let's let's get into it
right here
uh your mock draft you you really you
really think we got four quarterbacks
going
uh three quarterbacks going at the top
three in a row and you have
the 49ers taking mac jones you think
that's what they
coughed up all of that uh draft capital
go get is mac jones of alabama why
uh i i would take trade lance i'm just
gonna be honest i would take trade lands
from north dakota state
i think that he has the highest ceiling
of of the
the other quarterbacks after after the
top two
but i keep hearing you know the intel i
keep getting is that mac jones is going
to be the pick
listen i i understand like kyle shanahan
wants
he wants a guy that he knows it like
he can understand the game and he can
he has the same like brain that he has
and he can just throw them out there and
and if you look at the analytics like
from the um pressure qbr
to the blitz qbr to 21 plus yard gbr
matt jones has the best numbers but he's
not as
athletic as justin fields or train lance
and i don't know i i personally i i
would take lance but uh but
mac jones makes a lot of sense and
that's what everyone keeps telling me
our colleague bucky brooks on friday's
show said that he refers to mac jones as
uh iron man where um
where the suit makes him um
a superhero and the suit is alabama's
staff and team and um and that how many
times did you look at alabama and say
mack jones was the best player on the
field and you don't trade
all of that capital to go up and get
somebody
uh at the position who's not that speed
use the word pedestrian when he um
talked about mac jones
so your evaluation is
lance is the best of the three remaining
not named lawrence and wilson that's
your evaluation
on everything correct and then and then
fields are before
and then mack jones would be fifth
wow but you're hearing it's you're
hearing
otherwise it's going to be jones hearing
it but i i
it's hard to buy it to be completely
honest you know
i i keep looking at this and i think
about kyle
shanahan watching matt ryan
you know getting out of fuel field uh
field goal position
in in the uh super bowl and and losing
that super bowl
and then watching patrick mahomes
run around in the second half and extend
plays with that mobility
and i know that he wants i know he wants
in football intelligence and i know what
he's had before
but it just to me don't you want someone
that you can
develop and has a higher ceiling so it's
it's going to be fascinating to see i
mean the draft really starts at three we
know the first two picks you just
mentioned them
but the the draft really starts at three
and then you get to atlanta at four
and i don't think they want to take your
quarterback
i i think they want to give matt ryan a
a weapon
but i think they're going to take the
quarterback the more i study it
just because they know that they have to
set themselves up
for success for the next like 10 years
you know so before we get to that though
just
one last thing on this quarterback
evaluation todd mcshea of espn here on
the rich island show 10 days
before the nfl draft on espn abc and
then
my coverage on nfl network right here on
the rich eisen show
what do you like about lance because
again there's a pro day second
pro day of his and again we'll get some
footage but there's no live coverage of
it no wall to wall stuff right here uh
we
know that fields had a second shot at a
pro day and did according to albert
breer take requests from the
from the uh coaching uh staffs that were
there like 10
10 plays uh being requested that he he
run and throw from nfl scouts and
coaches who are there
what what about lance what do you like
about him for the one guy that
perhaps few people have seen play
he's built like a tight end he's strong
he's so competitive he can he
extends plays he has a big time arm
his biggest issue is that he
mechanically
his footwork is not where it needs to be
and footwork equals
ball placement i mean that's that's how
it works so
he needs to go somewhere where he can
probably sit for a year
and that's why i think san francisco at
three makes sense atlanta at four makes
sense
where you can sit behind a jimmy
garoppolo for a year or
or matt ryan and have the time to work
on the things that he needs to work on
he started 17 games rich
at the fcs level but
you just like when i watch him i see so
much potential i just think that he has
a chance to be a star in the league
but he needs the right developing
todd mcshea here on the rich eisen show
let's get into what the
the falcons are are thinking uh at four
and you said you know you think they're
going to take a quarterback on your mock
though you you
you have them doing what i think they
should do
you got matt ryan for two years on a
contract at least
that you have redone and no it'll be so
expensive to get out of it
you got julio jones when he's healthy
he's still julio jones calvin ridley is
stupendous you put kyle pitts there go
to work and see who can beat you 40 to
30 go for it
um and arthur smith the offensive
mindset that he can bring to the
equation here
it's just too too much to pass up
because when ryan's done you got pits
there
as a hall of fame potential talent for
the next guy with ridley
i might add for a long time to come what
do you think
it's i've been doing this for for 20
years
rich and i've i've never given a tight
end
a grade this high i mean that that's
that's how different he is and unless
you're like
you can call him you can call him a wide
receiver and a tight end body whatever
you want to do
but his wingspan his ability to get off
the press
his ability to separate with his feet
and then
to go up and make contested catches
in addition to making yards after
contact and yards after catch
it's it's rare you don't find a guy like
that so
yeah you match him up with julio and
calvin ridley
and all of a sudden now it you're giving
your organization a chance to make a run
the next couple of years
and i know matt ryan's not gonna be
there forever but he's been durable
he's been productive we know he can
still play the game
i would go i would vote kyle pitts but i
also know that the organization
is looking at it and saying all right
we're not planning to
draft it number four again we plan on
being
you know a playoff team so it's a very
difficult decision but i think
there's no question the first three
picks are gonna be quarterbacks
san francisco didn't move up from 12 to
three to take a a linebacker or a guard
or
you know they're taking a quarterback so
do you take that fourth quarterback
are you in love with that guy or do you
take the best
non-quarterback on the board and that's
kyle pitch
and then you've got uh at six and seven
the dolphins having
the choice of a wide receiver not named
jamar chase who you have the bengals
hooking up
once again with joe burrow why do you
think devonte smith over jaylen waddle
um is that choice right there that one's
tough
i'll be honest it's really tough and it
was
tough coming off the this past season
because i
you know it was i guess recency bias
because i i have never seen a receiver
have
such a successful season in college
football
is is devante smith had and jaylen
waddle goes down
and i had to go back to 2019 and started
the tape on jamar
chase from lsu and what he did i mean he
set season
you know single season records for the
sec
in terms of receiving yards and
receiving touchdowns
when he had joe burrow there and so i
jamar chase to me is the
physically the most gifted wide receiver
in this group
devonte smith is marvin harrison we've
talked about this before
he is he's silky smooth he knows how to
get open
he's not afraid to do the the dirty work
and then
and then you look at jalen waddle and
he's the most explosive player in the in
the country the last two years
and i'm talking you know screen game
quick game
run after catch and also the vertical
game too
so you're talking about three receivers
that are elite
prospects but i think it goes chase and
then it's a
kind of a tie breaker between devonta
smith and and jaylen waddle and i i
could understand if you go waddle over
smith but
i would personally go smith over waddle
just
based solely on on what we've seen but
again like in the first four games
last year when when wado was healthy he
had 13
fewer catches and 74 more yards
i mean that think about that 13 fewer
catches 74 more yards like that's how
explosive he is
and then uh as we move matriculate down
your your mock here todd mache of espn
um you have christmas coming early
because
you had um the lions taking whoever's
not smith
or waddle then you've got patrick
certain dropping to
or or the choice of carolina which means
jc horn is the guy at 10 for the
cowboys but you have you have uh trey
lance dropping to the
broncos and then justin fields falling
out of the top
ten for the patriots to go
up and grab with micah parsons still
sitting there for the eagles and penis
paneer sewell for the chargers i mean
like that is christmas coming early for
every team that i essentially just
mentioned
team's gonna get lucky right right there
all of them
if the first four teams are quarterbacks
and yes you only have one more
quarterback and it could be justin
fields
and does he go nine to denver or does
new england trade up from
from 15 to eight or you know get get in
position to go get him
that's the part that i struggle with but
you have five quarterbacks that are
likely to go in the first
10 12 spots and you have four pass
catchers including kyle pitts
that are likely to go in the first 10
spots as well so
everything everyone else gets pushed
back from the offensive tackles pine
sewell from oregon
uh rashaan slater from from northwestern
the corners patrick certain
uh from alabama uh jc horn from south
carolina
caleb farley from from virginia tech
like all these guys get pushed back
because there's such value in the
quarterbacks and the pass catchers
well i'll tell you what for the eagles
to you know tank game 256 to get up to
the sixth spot because let's be honest
and then for them to be able to trade
back to 12
get more picks for next year and still
get micah parsons who i know is not the
wide out that eagles fans have been
flipping out over or
look i don't think pitts would have
lasted till six anyway
but i you know and a kid from penn state
to just basically you know move a little
bit east to play his professional
football they would
that would be a hell of a pick and then
the chargers to get the guy the best
tackle to protect
their unicorn uh quarterback who has
shown himself to be a unicorn
my gosh that would be amazing but put it
all together though justin fields what
do you really think belichick's gonna
trade up from 15 or he's just gonna have
to wait till fields drops close enough
for him to be able to swallow that
concept i don't think that he's gonna
trade up
but every time i think i know what
bill's gonna do he does the opposite
you know and and this year has been so
different with the
the amount of money he spent free agency
right
and it's just i think he's
they didn't make the playoffs they've
had extra time to self-evaluate
and they realized that all right brady's
gone
we can't make up for all these sins that
we've been making up for for
for all these years with tom brady so
we've got to bring in talon they bring
bring in two tight ends they bring in
two receivers
they bring in edge guys you know like
they they spent
i think they spent more money than than
any team has ever spent in in free
agency history
and so well in 20 years two decades that
they
they have not used a first round pick on
a quarterback but they had brady the
whole time so why would you
so i i just you know i wonder if they're
going to make the move up i
my gut tells me they're not going to
they're going to stay home and maybe
it's micah parsons maybe it's
you know one of these defensive players
but but they're doing
they're doing everything differently
than they've they've done in in years
past and so i'm just i'm
so intrigued to see what new england
does that 15 pick or if they move up
or if they stay home or move back which
they typically do
and then uh in the the last third of
your mock todd mcshay before i let you
go
we see two stallion running backs going
back to back
you have the jets at 23rd overall
getting travis atn
and then the steelers jumping on naji
harris that would be
oh boy would steeler nation love that
kid from
alabama and if if this does happen that
means the jets were
one loss to the rams away one
one one lost or gets to the rams and and
browns away from getting
both you know uh trevor lawrence and
travis aten are getting both clemson
kids from the offense
and bringing them to new york uh why do
you think they would choose atn over
harris and
walk me through that um that period
right there tough call i
i actually have naughty harris rated
ahead of of travis etn
but i think joe douglas the gm and and
that organization i think they want
more explosiveness and that's etn is a
little bit more explosive he's the
the accelerator i call him he's just
like his one cut and go
and all of a sudden now you match him up
with with uh
zach wilson who they're going to take at
number two and you you've got a
backfield that is explosive and can
create after the initial play uh but i
listen i i would have no problem with
them taking naji harris because
nazi was 235 pounds dancing around for
the first two or three years
at alabama and then this past year he
turned into a pounder
and and he also was steve sarkisian the
offensive coordinator
he he became more of a weapon in the
passing game both of these guys said
if you go and look at the stats etn and
harris caught
i think almost double the amount of
passes that they caught
their first three years in their final
season
so they these guys have developed as
running backs
and they're ready for the nfl and i'm
not in love with taking a running back
in the first round
but if you're going to take a guy he's
got to be on the field all three downs
and both of these guys e.t and harris
can be on the field all three downs in
the nfl todd mcshay i am personally
excited for you
you know i'm one of those folks out
there um who you know knows that there's
competition don't mind talking about it
and promoting it
you know um i honestly i don't you know
i'm also an nfl
guy and you know the nfl has the draft
on three different networks including my
own
but i'm happy for you last year you
missed this because it covered
and i couldn't be more thrilled for you
to get out there do your thing
uh pound the table you know have have
your time you're on abc
correct you're gonna be part of the abc
card on abc with uh reese davis
kirkherb street and desmond howard and i
i can't wait man i i
i waited 20 years to get on the the
first night of the nfl draft
and then i got colbin and
i have been i have been grinding ever
since
to just get to this point i i honestly i
can't wait i'm so excited
i am fired up for you i am fired up for
you uh
thanks for the time here um look for
mike keep looking for my call
todd i'm gonna make it and thanks i
appreciate it you got it that's uh todd
mcshea here
on the rich eisen show he will be on the
abc coverage
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here